frohes neues jahr bla bla bla bla haben
uns die ganze scheiße der vision
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
youtuber erraten
das ist ein quiz wo man youtube erraten
muss mensch das halte ich am titel jetzt
gar nicht erkennen können so genannter
herz und er wohnte eine zeit lang mit
kelly zusammen definitiv ist mir egal
wer ist neu in der jury von das neue in
der jury von der c't hat sich von
falschen alter durch den bonnern deinen
kopf
wer ist neu in der jury von dsds melina
da gb shirin katja oder wie ich weiß
jetzt nicht auf welche staffel das rcb
zu dass ich jetzt gemacht
ich bin rechts gemacht einfach ich
glaube damit ist schirin gemeint weil
damit shirin gemeint ist wer hat eine
schnecke als mag was saft motto wenig
riskiert das zombie oder kino sam ich
weiß nicht warum man so sachen sind wie
wen interessiert das habe ich glaube
motto wenn ich mich nicht komplett
täusche kein schwert sie sind der
einmillionste besucher sie sind aus 100
exklusive finalistin 750 euro geschenkt
guthaben von saturn
das ist alles irreal wer ist für seine
kurzfilme bekannt zb herr bergmann
julien beben keinen plan oder taxi taxi
die kein plan ist definitiv auch hier
wieder richtig eigentlich will ich sagen
herr bergmann aber die scheiße ist halt
das studium eigentlich auch kurzfilme
macht das und deswegen an jpm und ist
auch für seine filme bekannt aber ich
glaube die wollen auf herr bergmann
hinaus wer lebt beziehungsweise lebte
mit einer freundin in amerika graphiker
street diese youtuber hofheim indes
julia ich würde eigentlich sagen diese
youtuber oder aber ich glaube die
monsees
wer trägt des öfteren zylinder autos
also ich würde sagen dass zombies
zylinder trägt so hast du gerade
gehustet die sache ist findet gerade im
hintergrund da hinten sitzt der hustet
die ganze zeit und das hat sich gar
nicht ab für den ton aber gut ich würde
sagen ey das heißt wir klicken auf
nächste frage wer es in der pornobranche
bekannt so ein mädel shirin katja einem
youtuber oder da gebe ich würde sagen an
der stelle ganz klar so ein mädel wer
zeigt sich nicht in der öffentlichkeit
geht mich nichts an grundschulen oder
glp ich würde sagen glp ja
ja wer macht mega aufwendige videos die
erste hand fort möglichkeit ist gibt es
das überhaupt auf wenn die videos nedas
gibt es das hätte ich nicht zumindest
nicht auf meinem kanal weil da ist alles
scheiße oder danke für deine qualitativ
hochwertigen bringen egal die kamera ist
er komplett schief wieso sagt ihr denn
nix alter wehrmacht mega aufwendige
videos wie bereits gesagt auf einem
kanal gibt es eher weniger ich würde
sagen julian bär macht mega aufwendige
videos haben indes yu na ja wer hat ein
schwein als maskottchen doors to the
bumper luton glp oder schweine sind süß
ich verstehe nicht wieso wir sind ganz
sind christel es immer so
antwortmöglichkeiten sind die einfachen
wirklich dumm sind schweine sind
süßwasser was ist das für eine antwort
das ist sich bei ihnen eine antwort
youtuber raten krasser boss alter in
krasser boss neun bis zehn richtig sie
haben zehn von zehn aufgaben richtig
beantwortet im durchschnitt haben die
1790 surfer die das gemacht haben fünf
was
zieht die alle dumm das war es jetzt
hier allerdings auch schon vom video
meine damen und herren da habe ich
wollte dass wir heute gar nicht mehr so
lange halten weil ich habe nicht viel
zeit und ich glaube dass ihr mich auch
gar nicht so lange ertragen können